are you tired of hearing that you're a
Pioneer or no it's great yeah yeah yeah
I am and that's like the greatest thing
you know because it was like amazing I
don't know how you know we were out
there doing comedy comedy when we didn't
even see other people like that look
like us doing it you were the only one I
saw yeah yeah it's incredible it's
really amazing you know what's so funny
and I'm kind of getting it too now where
like young people are coming up there
and go and you you know I'm doing it
because you know I mean yeah but it's so
funny because it's like I want to tell
them like I didn't do it for you
I did it for [__] no I'm not saying I
did it for like I'm you know this is I
naturally I would just gravitate it to
her it's great it but it's like brave
enough to do it yeah that's the thing to
be brave enough oh and not listen to
anybody out there or to not listen to
the The Silence Of No Asian voices out
there anyway that's what what it is but
it was also much and we can we admit
this
it was much harder for us it was totally
difficult it was so much we didn't know
that this time was coming that there
would be a lot of Asian American
comedians right I didn't know so it was
just like we're just doing we're trying
yeah we did it don't found it just did a
show maybe three weeks ago in Koreatown
and I did it good and we were in the
little area where the comics are and I'm
telling you I had
Goosebumps when I so I'm sitting there
dumb's there and there's nine Comics all
Asian mm-hmm
most of them are people you know on TV
yeah this and that right and I just
looked and I went oh my it's just kind
of like
impacted me in a very like
spiritual way so cool yeah it was just
like I can't believe this this is insane
the whole audience you know I mean was
Asian it was just like a whole thing
where I was just like because you know
when Margaret and I were doing it it was
no one nobody nothing not even there
would be two Asians in the audience yeah
yeah yeah there was like wait when we
were starting like who was it was Tamayo
otsuke lover yeah who was the one that I
saw before me she was great great but um
that was it I think and then Johnny you
Johnny I know I met him I met him yeah
yeah nice guy that's a nice guy yeah
um but his opening line was yeah and
that was his punchline but he was really
like um the only one yeah and then yeah
before that I don't know you're the
first one though that spoke like regular
English yeah and also had a point of
view that I could relate to like oh
she's just like me yeah like an American
yeah you're man you were the first one
yeah that's insane yeah it's so crazy
it's so insane but you know just like
there there was this Spirit of like you
want to just do it you don't care yeah
What it Took I thought that I was just
gonna be like an open Miker in San
Francisco and that I would have like um
a business where I would be scenting
lotion with a kind of rain and
um Peach yeah yeah cucumber yeah and um
that that would I would do that during
the day and then when Headliners came in
I would emcee yeah that's what I thought
oh then that's enough for me yeah you
know and that would be fine but
fortunately it was a little bit do you
remember when you noticed that oh this
is this might I might be able to turn
this into a thing I don't
I don't know yeah yeah um I mean I think
like I just was satisfied with so little
that now it just kept growing of like oh
this is actually getting better and then
I was excited about it so I think the
first sign for a comic is becoming
regulars at a club yeah at a club yeah
so that's I think that's first sign so
whenever like I'm at The Comedy Store
and like Chappelle Lacey just got passed
oh wow and I was in the back with him
and he had his like first main room show
I was back there and I looked at him I
go hey man congratulations it's not a
big deal yeah and he's like thank you
but I just know that that's a big kind
of landmark yeah for sure right really
good and then the next thing is probably
headlining a bee room yeah right
headlining at all at all yeah yeah yeah
yeah any kind of
being able to have that much time to do
yeah yeah even though you don't draw you
know what I mean that's hard still doing
it yeah still be able to stay up there
all that whole time it's so it's great
it's great yeah yeah and then then back
in our day was your first TV spot oh
yeah yeah such a big deal huge milestone
such a big deal what's your first one uh
my first television spot was MTV's half
hour Comedy Hour wow and then
um
then you would do like evening The
Improv and then a comic strip live and
then uh comedy on the road yeah and then
you would do I did Star Search hello
um and then I did
um the Bob Hope special wow so old and
you did all did you meet him yeah nice
yeah
um he couldn't hear you very well and he
couldn't see you very well and
um so he was just so old he was so old
yeah and he would do his sets like he
would do comedy in the beginning of the
special and uh they would be able to get
one or two words out and then they would
cut it together to the other you know he
would put together a set of five minutes
but it took like a week wow they would
do like little pieces and so it was all
kind of in the editing oh wow nice guy
but just super old so old yeah yeah
um and Phil Stiller was there so old and
so but she was very on top of it very
spicy imagine like imagine being on a
show
yeah I can't even imagine it yeah
they're like Legends of the [__]
thing incredible it's incredible so so
probably during that time you were like
this is working yeah during that time I
would like well you know I guess this is
going to be a good job and then I was
embarrassed I was at a party at JJ
Abrams house because he and I he and I
were playing piano and uh I was do the
the age not HBO but uh Bob Hope was on
and I was embarrassed that it was on and
and then somebody said oh she's on TV
right now until everybody made everybody
watch it I was so embarrassed wow but it
was like I I was there kind of like oh I
guess it was kind of this is kind of I
think might be that's a huge deal yeah
and also playing piano with JJ Abrams is
pretty cool so pretty crazy he's cool he
wasn't probably who he was he was a
writer but he um yeah he he had had like
uh just made regarding Henry that movie
all right and um yeah he was just
starting out pretty much yeah yeah but
yeah he was really cool wow what a
[__] what a life yeah
and it's not over no hopefully no you
have another 30 years maybe more 40.
let's see
before I get in that box
I think maybe yeah I would like to I
would like to be like old like the
people that live in Okinawa oh yeah you
know like really really old that's kind
of my goal so yeah but in Okinawa we
should come because it's very communal
right and they don't lock their doors
and if a kid wanders off he's safe
because the whole village is